to me Sam Harris the great Sam Harris is
somebody I've looked up to for a long
time
as a beacon a voice of reason and
there's this meme on the internet and I
would love you to steal man the case for
it and against that Trump broke Sam
Harris's brain
that there's something is
disproportionately to the actual impact
that Trump had on our society he had
an impact on the div on the ability of
balanced calm rational Minds to see the
world clearly to think clearly you being
one of the beacons of that is there is
there a degree to which he broke your
brain
uh well Otherwise Known As Trump Duran
medical what's up yeah I mean I think
Trump derangement syndrome is a very
clever meme because it it just uh throws
the you know the problem back on the
person who's criticizing Trump but in
truth the true
Trump derangement syndrome was not to
have seen how dangerous and divisive it
would be to promote someone like Trump
to that position of power and to not and
in the in the final moment not to see
how
uh untenable it was
to still support someone who you know a
sitting president who was not committing
to a peaceful transfer of power I mean
that was if if that wasn't a bright line
for you you have been deranged by
something uh because that was you know
the that was one minute to midnight for
our democracy as far as I'm concerned
and I think it really was but for
the the Integrity of a few people that
we didn't suffer some real
constitutional crisis and and real
emergency you know after January 6. I
mean if Mike Pence had caved in and
decided to non-certify the election
right uh literally you can count on two
hands a number of people who held things
together at that moment and so it was so
it wasn't for want of trying on Trump's
part that we we um
didn't succumb to some you know real
truly Uncharted uh uh catastrophe with
our democracy so the fact that that
didn't happen
is not a sign that those of us who were
worried that it was
so close to happening we're exaggerating
the problem I mean it's like you know
you almost got run over by a car but you
didn't and so you know you're the fact
that you're adrenalized and you're
thinking you know but boy that was
dangerous I probably shouldn't you know
you know wander in the middle of the
street uh with my eyes closed
um you weren't wrong to feel that you
really had a problem right
um
and came very close to something truly
uh terrible so I think that's where we
were and I think we shouldn't do that
again right so the fact that he's he's
still he's coming back around as
potentially a viable candidate you know
I'm not spending much time thinking
about it frankly because it's you know
I'm I'm waiting for the moment where it
requires some thought
um I mean it did
it took up
uh I don't know how many podcasts I
devoted to the topic
it wasn't that I mean it wasn't that
many in the end you know against the the
number of podcasts I I devoted to other
topics but there are people who look at
Trump and just find him funny
entertaining
not especially threatening is like not a
you know just it's just good fun to see
somebody who's like who's just not
taking anything seriously and it's just
just putting a you know a stick in the
wheel of of business as usual again and
again and again and again
um
and they don't really see anything much
at stake right it doesn't really doesn't
really matter if we don't support NATO
it doesn't really matter if he says he
trusts Putin more than our intelligence
Services uh I mean none of this is it
doesn't matter if he's on the one hand
saying that he loves uh
the leader of North Korea and on the
other threatening is threatens to to you
know bomb them back to the Stone Age
right on Twitter
it's all it all can be taken in the
spirit of kind of reality television
it's like this is just this is the part
of the movie that's just fun to watch
right and
I understand that I can even inhabit
that space for a few minutes at a time
but
there's a deeper concern that we're in
the process of entertaining ourselves to
death right that we're just not taking
things seriously and this is it's a
problem I've had with several other
people we might name who just who just
appear to me to be goofing around at
scale and they lack a kind of moral
seriousness I mean they're touching big
problems where lives hang in the balance
but they're just around and
I think they're really important
problems that we have to get our head
straight around
and we need you know it's not to say
that that institutions don't become
corrupt I think they do and I think and
I'm quite worried that you know both
about the the loss of trust in our
institutions and the
the fact that trust has eroded for good
reason right that they have become less
trustworthy I I think you know they've
become infected by
you know political ideologies that are
not truth tracking I mean I I worry
about all of that
um
but I just think the we need
institutions we need to rebuild them we
need
we need experts who are real experts we
need to Value expertise over
you know amateurish speculation and
conspiracy thinking and just you know
and the kind of amateur
speculation we're doing on this very
podcast
I'm usually alert to the moments where
I'm
just guessing or where I actually feel
like I'm talking from within my
wheelhouse and I try to Telegraph that a
fair amount with people
um
so yeah I mean it but it's not
it's different like I mean you you can
invite someone onto your podcast who's
an expert if that's something that
you're you you're not an expert
about and then you
you in the process of getting more
informed yourself your your audience is
getting more informed so you're asking
smart questions and you might be pushing
back at the margins
but you know that when push comes to
shove on that topic you really don't
have a basis to have a a strong opinion
and
if you were going to form a a a strong
opinion that was this counter to the
expert you have in front of you it's
going to be by deference to some other
expert who you've brought in or who
you've heard about or whose work you've
read or whatever but there's a paradox
to
how we value Authority in science that
most people don't understand and I think
we should at some point unravel that
because it's the basis
for a lot of public confusion and
frankly it's the basis for a lot of you
know criticism I've received on these
topics where it's you know people think
that I'm a
you know I I'm against Free Speech or
I'm an establishment shill or it's it's
like I just think I'm a credit
credentialist I just think people with
phds from ivy league universities should
you know run everything
it's not true but there's a ton of confu
there's a lot to cut through to get to
Daylight there because people are
um
very confused about how we value
Authority in the service of rationality
generally